[Musique]
ouais
elle copine avec les grands patrons avec
les maîtres
elle copie avec le gouvernement jusqu'à
la haute autorité
elle dit avec eux
avec deux possibilités se serait il le
courant ce noyau
de faire attention à ce qu'elles
racontent pour ne pas froisser leurs
clients c'est nous sommes en
[Musique]
c'est pas obligatoire de leur imposer la
docilité
leur conscience et déjà broyer
elle aussi interchangeables que les
ministres
pensant différemment de telles
entreprises at-elle entreprises elles
défendent évidemment les intérêts de ces
mêmes entreprises
reprise de la direction des médias
l'équipe tentacules parmi d'autres
tentacules tout de même indispensable
indispensable et 6
ce qu'elle s'immisce tu elle s'immisce
dans la salle raid
à toulouse
un panneau applause fidèles applaudi
sans elle et elle n'a pu dire et panne
en fidèle réfléchir est morte fidèle
doit pas réfléchir non surtout pas
fidèle doit juste appeler au titre est
resté sur le monde
[Musique]
elles savent y faire à vrai dire c'est
leur métier
[Musique]
ce sont les ventouses
oui il vend tous
[Musique]
il vend tous ce sont celles et ceux qui
copine avec la tête de la pioche
les chiens cas
journaliste économiste spécialiste
éditorialistes philosophe chroniqueur
présentateur artistes stars quelconque
quiconque honda dans le capitalisme et
éviter quiconque réconfortant le
capitalisme et a invité les ventouses
elles sont nées dans une autre réalité
une autre planète une autre
constellation même au delà
après tout à chacun sa réalité n'est ce
pas
et la réalité c'est qu'une pâte à
modeler
une patte qu'ils trient pas lui
bien sûr qu'elles ne disent pas tout
nous dit a tout ce qu'il faut penser
ce qu'il faut croire ce qu il faut d
mais ce qu'il faut dénigrer ce qu'il
faut faire c'est de temps il faut se
méfier ce qu'il faut acheter commande ou
loger comment nous déplacer nous nourrir
nous divertir comment travailler sur
quoi il faut ensemble et même celles où
celle qu'il faut tenir
c'était tout de même pas une dictature
pas non il n'utilise pas la violence
ah bon c'est ça la rue
pourtant c'est bien une armée qui défend
les intérêts de la france
les armes
ainsi lorsqu'on entend notre
contestation
c'est bien de crs qui les boules
avec des armes
bien sûr jours pronostique moi je dis
qu'à la prochaine insurrection et iront
dans la foule
ils ont toujours fait partout
sauf que l'insurrection ne nous effleure
même pas l'esprit
de notre tête résident de silence
pensée dissidente est aspiré par des
ventouses
elles font semblant de réfléchir
et font semblant de se sentir concerné
elles font semblant d'être consterné par
notre histoire sanglante et recommence
elles font même semblant de débattre
mais qu'elle n'est pas
il n'y a que des des toits sans
contradictions des départs sont remises
en question n'était pas sans réflexion
et les vraies questions se remise à plus
tard
plus tard et remis à trop tard
être ta risque bien d'arriver trop tôt
entre-temps en trottine tranquille en
allant dans leur sens
mais le contrôle toute notre vie et tout
en les ans
[Musique]
tout croire qu'ils ont trouvé un moyen
efficace d'éviter la révolte
faire en sorte qu'on n'y pense pas tous
un peu
faire en sorte qu'on ne pense pas
comment
lâchez pas
personne ne sait vraiment
peut-être des gens
répétant sans cesse que ce système nous
va
par je ne sais quel processus
psychologiques ont fini par intégrer ces
dingues
c'est quand même plus malin que tu es
tout le monde comme à l'époque des nazis
enfin faut pas croire et dessus tout le
monde
pas tout le monde nous
et les autres ils sont loin
invisible en fait
et
[Musique]
un esclave obéit mieux lorsqu'il est
consentant alors nous laisse libres
en nous laisse dire ce qu'on veut on
nous laisse crier hurler même si on veut
encore faudrait-il que quelqu'un qui
nous entendre
on à droite je suis jeté à côté d'une
fanfare
c'est tout
de la france à la partie en milliardaire
en même temps c'est tentant
mais la liberté d'expression ce n'est
pas dire ce qu'on veut dire
c'est avoir la possibilité d'entente en
nombre et en temps
et on en est loin
[Musique]
communication unilatérale notre pinot
échoue sur une plage déserte
seuls à leur compte la leur au singulier
une seule opinion une seule société
possible le capitalisme le capitalisme
hameau tellement galvaudé continûment
à quoi bon c'est la seule économie
possible
[Musique]
si c'était faux
silver jews nous mentait
d'après tous les ans toujours menti
alors papa
parce qu'on est plan
parce qu'on est riche non il ferait pas
ça
quand même passé senet milliardaire
vendeurs d'armes françafrique un comble
quand même passer gentiment
[Musique]
les autres
sauf que les autres dictateurs en fait
ils ont été placés par les noirs
bah ouais pour financer leur campagne a
gagné nos élections du truc les leurs
alors
propagande
émotion télécommande ville humaine
relative mort relate et si et seulement
si le drame ne contrarie pas le
capitalisme
drame non relaté égale à 1000 existants
ce sont elles qui décident
il vend tous des sites il y vraiment non
ce qui existe ce qui est juste elles
peuvent prendre un mensonge et en faire
une évidence
il suffit qu'elle en suisse
[Musique]
ils nous veulent même des mots
démocratie
la chasse
la démocratie ce n'est pas donner le
pouvoir à une élite oligarques et
l'anarchisme
ce n'est pas le désordre ça n'a rien à
voir encadré
l'anarchisme
c'est un système éthique collégiale et
libertaire pensée pour éviter la
soumission la domination une autorité
et maintenant quand tu ranges patachon
m'ont dit que c'est l'anarchie
c'est pas mal de monde
[Musique]
des trafiquants
tous sont des trafiquants de certains
elles servent à bricoler dans nos crânes
pour faire de nous des consommateurs et
des producteurs
rien de plus étaples incruste dans nos
têtes pour faire de nous des acheteurs
et des travailleurs qui acceptent leur
monde injuste et ça marche
propagande ça les nazis avaient déjà
il faut à tout prix qu'on les a rachetés
ventoux avant que la pieuvre nous et
tout prix
par tous les moyens j'en ai liste
d'indépendants militantisme
manifestation
m
désobéissance et éducation populaire
association poésie bande dessinée
musique théâtre arts de rue roman est
celle cinéma toute forme d'art toute
forme de philosophie d'expression de
débat de réflexion de questionnements
d'action l'expérimentation d'alternative
de résistance d'existence tout
absolument tout ce qui contredit les
contredit les ventes ou c'est bon à
prendre
il faut sans cesse démentir leurs propos
c'est un travail de titan mais une fois
les ventouses bourreuse ne
s'accrocherait plus à nos rêves
mais ça sera pas trop
[Musique]
changer les mentalités c'est la première
étape
glissez nos ongles leur [ __ ] de
ventouses
détricoter le travail des médias
se libérer des tentacules
ne pas se contenter de se libérer soi
même d'en libérer les autres et laisser
les autres nous libérer
se libérer mutuellement
la pieuvre en fait ne fait pas le poids
elle pleure
les ventouses bluff
elles peuvent pas nous empêcher de
penser elle s'essaye à ces seuils sans
cesse
je n'ai arriveront jamais vous empêcher
de penser
[Musique]
danser
pensons à penser
[Musique]
pensons à penser penser autre que la
pensée imposé par les ventouses elle
même influencée par la pensée la pensée
la seule pensée soit disant bien
pensante qui soit dit en passant nous
pousse dans le précipice
si l'on s'y précipitent c'est parce que
les ventouses d'où l'on aspire et notre
pensée assez passons à autre chose
pensons autre chose pensons tout court
glissons nos ongles sous leurs [ __ ]
de ventouses et penchons nous sur notre
pensée elle bluffe je vous dis les
ventouses bluff
nous n'avons qu'à penser mais c'est nous
on ne se leurre ventouses et juste pensé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]